THE BUZZ SPREAD QUICKER
THAN THE SMILE ACROSS MY FACE
WHEN I ARRIVED TO WORK
EACH MORNING.
HOW MANY CAPPUCCINOS
CAN I GET FOR YOU?
- JUST THE ONE, PLEASE.
- [laughs] OKAY.
$3.50.
THANK YOU.
THERE WERE NO TWO WAYS
ABOUT IT--I LOVED MY JOB,
TO THE POINT
WHERE I BEGAN TO FORGET
THAT IT WASN'T MY REAL JOB.
[knocks on counter]
- EXCUSE ME.
- OH, WE'RE NOT OPEN YET, SIR--
OH, GRANT.
HI.
- HEY.
DO YOU HAVE A SECOND TO TALK?
- UH...
- JUST FOR A SEC?
- YES.
- YEAH.
- HOW'S THE SHOW GOING?
- WELL...
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
'CAUSE WE'RE WAITING FOR YOU
TO QUIT THIS JOB.
- OH, YEAH.
QUIT THIS JOB?
- THAT'S WHY YOU TOOK THIS JOB
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
- I WAS THINKING OF--
MAYBE I WOULD CUT DOWN MY HOURS
ONCE I GET THINGS UP TO SPEED,
'CAUSE I HAVE
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT--
- WELL,
YOU'RE REVIEWING QUITTING.
VIEWERS NEED THIS.
- YEAH.
- AMERICA NEEDS THIS,
AND THE WORLD NEEDS THIS.
- SIX MINUTES UNTIL THE PASTRIES
ARRIVE, MR. FORREST.
- DO WE UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER
OR WHAT?
- [sighs]
- FORREST, GET OUT HERE.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOMETHING.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
"LOBBY JAVA BY FORREST."
- UH, WILLY...
I'M REALLY SORRY. UH...
[clears throat]
YOU KNOW,
WHEN I FIRST STARTED HERE,
I BELIEVED IN WHAT
WE WERE DOING.
NOW I'M NOT SO SURE.
- WHAT?
- BUT THERE IS, UH,
ONE THING I KNOW.
YOU'RE THE BIGGEST JAG-OFF
I'VE EVER WORKED FOR.
- FORREST...
- AND I HOPE THIS PLACE--
UGH--
BURNS TO THE GROUND
WITH YOU IN IT,
BECAUSE THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT YOU DESERVE,
YOU NICKEL-AND-DIME
CHICKEN[bleep] MOTHER[bleep].
OH, BOY.
YOU CALL YOURSELF A MANAGER?
YOU COULDN'T MANAGE
A HAM SANDWICH!
[clears throat]
OKAY, I AM LEAVING HERE,
AND I AM NEVER COMING BACK,
NOT IF YOU BEG ME!
WHO'S WITH ME?
- I AM!
- OH.
- IF MR. FORREST GOES, I GO!
- OH, GOD.
- YOU COULDN'T MANAGE
A HAM SANDWICH!